the number of homes and businesses
damaged by harvey could be in the
thousands including our cbs houston
affiliate khou
water gushed into the first floor in the
studio in the middle of yesterday's live
broadcast employees were forced to
evacuate but one of the reporters stayed
on the air and what she did went viral
and she has already been seen all around
the world thanks to being in the right
place at the right time brandy smith was
able to help save a life sir are you are
you okay can you get to the top of your
vehicle
brandi smith was reporting live when she
saw this semi truck stranded on the
roadway below her the cab was quickly
filling up with water the driver still
inside the water here is about it's it's
going on 10 feet deep
you do not climb into the water my first
thought was just that we had to figure
out a way to get him out i couldn't walk
away knowing that there was someone in
that truck suddenly she spotted a rescue
vehicle on the highway we have a boat
coming we have a boat coming i'm going
to flag i'm going to flag these guys
down as the freeway off-ramp became a
boat ramp smith tried to reassure the
truck driver they're on their way
i was terrified i was absolutely
terrified from the moment we saw him i
had promised him that help was on the
way and i wasn't i wasn't gonna break
that promise she continued reporting
while her own newsroom had begun to
flood that's the water level on the
glass
with crews scrambling to move their
cameras upstairs to broadcast from a
conference room but as water continued
pouring into the building how long do
you think that door will hold the
decision was made to evacuate leaving
smith and her photographer mario
sandoval as the only people broadcasting
for one of houston's largest stations
those are the kind
of circumstances we're dealing with
catastrophic
dire life-threatening smith remained on
the air for almost 30 minutes by herself
her camera was rolling as rescuers
pulled the truck driver out through a
window i feel like i can finally breathe
kind of a sigh of relief i don't know if
i could have lived with any other
outcome so i am so grateful that the
sheriff's deputies came along with when
they did now you thank god that you guys
were right here to get me put me back on
land safe i appreciate you can i this is
gonna sound weird but can i hug you for
smith it was like nothing she'd ever
experienced when a live shot may have
actually helped save a life
so really brandy did such an incredible
job as you know trying to report the
situation here in houston but first and
foremost concerned about the lives of
other houstonians and able to get him
the the help that he need
needed
nora what an amazing story yeah i don't
think that's weird at all that she
wanted to hug him we were wondering how
are they able to stay on the air they
were on there with facebook live that's
why she was able to stay and we could
see that story that's not weird at all
it's i'd like to hug him right now
i feel that too
brandi smith i have a feeling they'll
stay in touch